a bit of it had a bit of a panic attack
i've been developing an app it's not a
matrimony app um it's it's up to build i
realize there's
foundational problems within the
seeking marriage getting married divorce
there's a lot of problems so that's why
working on the app i developed the app
but now i'm putting the content i've
been filming the content
so i've got a little bit more to film
once that's up my aim was to release the
documentary part one and also market
the app they go hand in hand my purpose
is to make sure that the app has
everything that i went through in my
marriage journey and what what i um what
i was searching for the mistakes that i
made um the the things that i learned so
i don't want people to go through the
same mistakes i made to my aim i've said
to myself you know what by next year
if the app is ready it's not ready
inshallah i'm going to release part one
if it's ready it's not because all this
time the app has been causing the delay
it would have been out two years ago so
because of the app i was nearly done
that problem okay let's wait a bit
longer i've come to the point i said
look next year
personally i don't like giving this
cause every time i mention something
publicly it doesn't happen but inshallah
that's my deadline
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
so my eyes character
is a thing about a video game think
about a movie you think about a book
you have different characters the
character
is uh the expressions the actions the
personality the traits of this
individual
good character would imply obviously
that this person leads
towards good bad would imply that they
lean towards bad but having character in
general uh implies authenticity or at
least i would say good character implies
authenticity
assalamu alaikum
welcome back to the realest podcast in
the dunya the three muslims where we're
backstage for exclusive access with
alidawah who has information about the
release date for the mayor's documentary
salaam alaikum
i see you getting personal now i can see
it asking some personal questions there
you know
let's get right on bro when's the date
that's a good question i mean i'm in
talks with netflix um
you know we are discussing you know the
project
yeah i think um
you know the mars documentary project is
something
very close to my heart so
you know sometimes i was i was very
confused between does allah not want it
to come out or is it shaytan so i was
very confused is it something allah
doesn't want so about two years ago
something happened where i thought okay
no it can't be allah
because
the doc i lost i lost some parts of the
documentary i've got some but then i
found somebody who helped me edit it and
put part one
part two and a bit of part three
together okay no this can't be from
allah that allah doesn't want it to come
up because if that was the case
this wouldn't happen it has come
together so i think allah is waiting for
the right time
to enable me to drop it
uh part one is out on my channel
mohammed hijab saw it
zeeshan saw a bit of it had a bit of a
panic attack
um but yeah it's gonna come out
inshallah but i've been developing an
app it's not a matrimony app um it's
it's an app to build i realize there's
foundational problems within the
seeking marriage getting married divorce
there's a lot of problems so that's why
i'm um
working on an app i developed the app
but now i'm putting the content i've
been filming the content
so i've got a little bit more to film
once that's up my aim was to release the
documentary part one and also market
the app they go hand in hand
um so yeah that's why i'm waiting for
and that's not for financial reasons
i'll be honest with you i'm not a money
motivated person
um this doesn't mean i would never
become money motivated what i'm trying
to say is from now from what i know of
myself i know my weaknesses i know okay
you know what that's a weakness that's a
weakness that's not weakness so it's not
a point of money uh per se even though
obviously when you do the app you will
be charging but my aim is
my purpose is to make sure that the app
has everything that i went through in my
marriage journey and was what i um what
i was searching for the mistakes that i
made um the the things that i learned so
i don't want people to go through the
same mistakes i made and i know marriage
is a massive issue i know it's a massive
issue i know if i release a documentary
it will inshallah if i don't care if it
does or not the point is even if 20
people watch it they benefit but i know
it's a big problem so a problem like
that you have to deal with it very
carefully not haphazardly so i'm very
careful that's the reason why
i haven't released it yet uh but my aim
i've said to myself you know what by
next year valentine's day if the app is
ready it's not ready inshallah i'm gonna
release part one if it's ready sorry
because all this time the app has been
causing the delay it would have been out
two years ago so because of the app i
was nearly done that problem okay let's
wait a bit longer i've come to the point
i said look next year valentine's day
because valentine's day is haram and
zina is the tackle that so next year
valentine's day personally i don't like
giving this because every time i mention
something publicly it doesn't happen but
inshallah that's my deadline
yeah
all right fair play
i mean i mean i mean i mean i mean let's
get into that what are some of the
issues that you see today with marriage
especially in the muslim community all
right so this is a marriage podcast yeah
okay
are you probably single is that what's
going on you want to
i mean i'm married and the other two but
rami is engaged yeah i'm married rami's
engaged
okay we need to talk about that's very
interesting but before we go there um
the brother on this side
what's your name
yeah there you go that was perfect bro
yeah yeah was that good yeah yeah
mashallah angel yeah yeah yeah okay i'm
single bro i'm singing beautiful aki i
don't know how you look like that and
you're single and handsome brothers
mashallah i'm going to say you know they
see
i think the sisters they are lowering
the gates too much you know
[Laughter]
mashallah now we definitely have to talk
about that because after angel reverted
last year he had some questions about
where do we find muslim women
and i was like bro i don't know because
i'm not i don't do online stuff so
you know so we can go into that
i think i think when i was going for a
marriage journey bro i went full out
because you see i think there's a hadith
of the prophet salallahu sallam when he
was going to war and he had two armors
on
now with us if he was with rasulullah
we'll be thinking you're the messenger
of allah like come on put it trust in
allah like logically like you know
you know or rasulullah you're the one
who's closest to allah the messenger of
allah wearing two armor
the the point is this is that even with
him to understand the truth essence of
islam he had double armor on
the point is not oh under a solo a
messenger of god almighty and i'll just
go jump off i'm trying to say so the
thing is you tie your camel you tie your
camel properly you know so the thing is
people people have this huh
yeah how did you know
yeah he just asked me because you want
some water we just came from the gym and
i'm really first i was just about to ask
him john
you know our friendship is so close you
can realize i'm thirsty
so yeah yeah when it comes to that aki
tying your camel it shouldn't be like
yeah i'm you know i'm pious you know i
just sit at home and i wait for the
sister to come um end up in this famous
sofa yeah so the thing is i looked at
all means i went to marriage events yeah
there's marriage events um i want to say
per se they were very very halal where
you go there so there's eight tables and
there's four sisters and four brothers
and the brothers usually move from table
to table so you'll come okay you sit
down so i'm like my name's ali um i
don't know i'm this year's old um i do
this
i'm kurdish
so you give your name and then you have
your name with um name or you have a
number yeah okay the number you like
like a cow you know
so the the thing is you're numbered so
if a sister finds a liking or you find
it lacking in a sister you write the
numbers okay so for example sister
number nine that looks fine i'm not i'm
not rapping right there
so you write it down and at the end of
it there wally's there so one thing that
was good is that they can bring their
wali some didn't but the thing is the
conversation is done in that area and
this you know there's people there
and there's pros and cons to this this
person comes to everything so at the end
of the day that can carry on outside
those buildings which is the danger but
that can happen with anything that can
you could do that when you're walking
down the road you can try to speak to a
sister or anyone so thank you
so the thing is it's totally up to you
to keep it
halal come on single like the video man
smash that like button with that i went
to those events i've approached sisters
on instagram i approached the sister on
facebook for marriage
i even approached the sister in person
when i mean in person so i was walking
in i was in a shopping center and my i
happened to catch
so he just he's making me laugh
so i happened to see her and i
approached it but the thing is there's
there has to be a certain adap uh to
approach him i'm trying to say and
there's pros and cons with that because
it can go wrong because if she's married
if well imagine her brother's there so
there's pros and cons there's a way like
if i had a sister i would get my sister
to go to be on the safe side you get it
or if for example
i don't know man if i'm somewhere and
there was a sister there and i said oh
sister you know i'm interested in this
stuff it might be okay but the thing is
i didn't find that and i thought you
know what look my intentions are in the
right place but obviously i went and
because she was with their friend
and you know you observe yeah it's it's
you you observe and i mean observe you
know you see if you're liking but then i
approached and i said look sorry sister
i have no ill bad intentions i'm
genuinely seeking marriage and i want to
speak to your dad if you're looking to
get married that's it yes no i'm not
interested about this that so that did
happen um i did get to know her it
didn't work out but the point is there
is a and in the marriage documentary i
asked this question to mufti mink about
approaching um and so we discussed that
in detail but the thing is it's it's up
on you there's marriage uh web um apps
you know i don't need to mention here i
was on one of them when i first came to
islam in 2013 because i didn't have a
muslim surrounding i don't know where
i'm going to find a sister so the thing
is i had to um go on there and to me it
was devastating man like because it was
it was so really bad you know like
i go into the details in the documentary
but bro if if i didn't come from a
jahilia
and it was as good as her own
relationships it was good as
meeting now i didn't know nothing about
wally meeting the dad getting to i knew
nothing all i knew is okay i want to get
i want to get to know her for marriage
that's my purpose my intentions are
there but your intentions mean nothing
because when you go meet these
individuals you're meeting them
in public but then you're going okay
let's go to eat because i'm still in the
jahlil mindset because i'm new to islam
and i'm thinking okay i need to get to
know i don't know about this whole
concept of wali etc so i saw a lot of
i would say girls with bad intentions
and i'm talking girls yani with
who's this brother
no he turned off his camera man all
right i was gonna say
so yeah it's it's it's how you
you need to make sure that you do your
bit
you look everywhere and try your best
and you leave the rest allah
i think that's um
alhamdulillah i think that's that's
really proper advice really well-rounded
because
uh you basically have two extremes you
have the extreme of the people are like
i'm gonna sit at home and shut up one
day a man is going to come to my door
and look after his marriage and then you
have the other extreme that's like um
i'm going to do it myself you know i'll
need help and they they don't even make
god they don't even really bring along
to the airport
yes yes exactly there's two extremes
because the thing is what you're doing
is and everything when it comes to the
marriage problem and everything it all
ties into tahit
and people don't understand
everything bro even the sisters who are
wearing the hijab nowadays the fringe
showing yeah or the brothers who are
selling they need to provide they want
to get married they want to provide all
this is a lack of tawak because what
you're doing is you're saying i have to
show my beauty
to find someone that's attractive to me
so what you're basically saying is i am
control of getting married not allah and
i would take in my hands and i would
dress up in a tight dress so he can be
argumented i'm not saying oh or the
brothers who will go and sell
certain things or get into haram
relationships because what they're
saying is it's in my hands they don't
have trust in allah so they're saying
the matter is in my hands what can i do
what does society want okay i'm gonna do
that so this is where this is one of the
reasons why i wanted to
develop this app that i'm working on
because it's to build foundations and we
go in detail about this stuff because if
you don't have these foundations you're
going to be like malcolm x's if you
don't stand for something you're going
to fall for anything and this is the
reason why sisters taking their job if
they feel ugly you know and that's why i
don't believe when sisters come and say
oh you know i choose to talk to hijab
off you didn't choose to take hijab off
and oh i chose to wear the hijab i know
you didn't choose to wear the hijab i
didn't choose to grow the beard i didn't
choose to wake up for fajr i didn't
choose to dress up modestly i didn't
allah told me to now somebody will come
and say ah that's why you're oppressed
no i'm not oppressed because i have two
options number one i follow what society
tells me to do do or i i i follow what
allah tells me to do who deserve it of
my worship allah you are following
society so when somebody comes and says
oh i choose to dress up in a mini skirt
and by the way i don't look down on
anyone i believe some there might be a
sister who might be in a miniskirt today
might be better than me a thousand times
two three years later the point is this
someone who dressed up in the minuscule
i genuinely asked him do you genuinely
want to dress up like that
really or is it that societal pressure
you made it feel ugly do you love it
that you wake up in the morning and you
spend two hours on your makeup and make
sure your makeup is on fleek and make
sure you know everything your nails can
you imagine how hard that is bro i need
to make sure my nails on point you know
they have to be this color and put some
little diamonds on them and the same
with the brothers you know guy into the
gym etc i live that lifestyle going to
the gym why to for me not necessarily
maybe twenty percent of me twenty the
rent is seventy eighty percent was
impressed opposite gender
so when people come and say i'm free
you're not free um sorry i don't know
about tangent but yeah
yeah i don't i don't like it when women
wear that much makeup easy like it just
it
it confuses me because like you see them
and like from afar you're like hmm like
she masha allah and then you get close
you're like whoa this this girl is caked
up
yeah this isn't real
but you see you know sisters who wear
hijab i don't want to make this a
sister's thing yeah okay because at the
end of the day i try to address
both genders okay both of them but
for a man the one thing that i need to
understand and this is what this one
thing that we discuss as well yeah is
that men can fall in love the wrong way
yeah we can fall in love the wrong way
where are visual creatures you do not go
and see
men's magazines of a brother showing his
carves and the woman are selling it out
selling out women like oh let me let me
check those carves or hairy carves it
doesn't happen do you know what i'm
trying to say you don't
have uh for for for women very rare and
the ones that even go a study showed
that they only go when they have this
hendu you know in the uk they have this
thing where you know when a woman is
about to get married at a man they go
out and
they only go because their friends go
okay women don't have this inclination
visually we're very visual creatures so
what sisters don't understand is that
they can make us fall in love the wrong
way i can fall in love in the wrong part
of you as your whole body i can be i can
be like you know what like if you get
i'm trying to say and once and sadly in
today's time that's what you think it's
all beauty once i marry you and i see
when the makeup comes off
and and shaytan beautifies aki sometimes
and when someone told me the baba said
if you see these girls how they dressed
up in this class well life you saw them
naked you vomit
but they the dress they made is made to
so appealing but if you saw them in real
life like if they took their clothes off
yeah you'll be like wow does that look
so different it's all fake
so the point is as men what happens is
when you dress up like this you are
bound to attract a lot of men you're
going to attract a lot of men but are
these men for there for the right
reasons and that's the reason why a lot
of women a lot of women suffer
mentally and in a lot of ways
and they suffer why because if you think
about it okay the biggest fraud and scam
is
um haram relationships it's the biggest
fraud for women it's the biggest fraud
because if you think about it a man is
gaining a relationship with a girl yeah
she thinks okay you know because women
they think it's like you know yeah it's
all cool um he loves me yeah they think
yeah okay love in his head he's there
for one thing he's young his hormones
are flying rocketing all over the place
so he
is there he guess what he wants he gets
bored and says we're not getting on we
know or whatever whatever excuse and
dumpster now he dumped her she's
thinking i didn't work out you know i'm
not compatible no no he's not compatible
he's bored of you he's bored he's moving
on to the next one now this cycle
continues and what woman don't think is
oh it didn't work out i hope it i hope
it doesn't happen with the same one when
you're using the same method and you
want different results how are you using
the same myth and i want different
resources islam comes and says well hold
on a second you have to speak to your
dad dad well i don't want to speak to
your dad why am i going to speak to your
dad i'm only here for one thing speak to
that that's a that's a long thing oh
after that what i need to give you maher
what my head how much three grand nah
panda i'm not gonna be three grand oh i
need to do a wedding and i need to
announce the wedding oh and if things
got peak i need to face up to your dad
and your brothers no thank you very much
i'd rather go and you know
sadly there's some industry where you
can go pay money and or you know i'm
saying like someone can say if i have
those urges i can go and pay i don't
know ten dollars whatever it is
i can go and do that so you see how
islam
systematically protects the woman and if
this was implemented bro wallahi let me
tell you something no woman would have
to i'm not trying to say women are all
victims yeah there are some women out
there that are dangerous yeah and in my
marriage journey i i've seen it
i've seen it brother trust me yeah and i
wouldn't want any brother to go through
the stuff that i went through you know
so the thing is i can't go into detail
because you know you have to watch the
documentary for that um
but the point is aki it's um
it's it's like i said before you know
sisters don't truly understand and what
happens if we don't have tawakkul in
allah and we live in a society bro
amazon prime fast food fast cars fast
hand dryers you go above hand drive in
10 seconds yeah you got the super
machines now this is true your hands
everything is so fast and with social
media our brains are wired like uh
psychologists say uh neurons that fire
together neurons that fire together wire
together so the thing is we are created
in such a way
not created we are programmed in such a
way that everything we want fast and we
implement this into our marriage and our
friendship and all kinds of things so
when we have a district with a friend
i'll ban him i'll replace him there
where is the attitude come from
sometimes i see some brothers having to
dispute each other oh this is i'm not
brother hold on a second man did you
guys have good times how did you how did
you forget it so quickly why is it so
like replaceable where's this attitude
coming from it's our society you know
and that's why we have this culture of
replace easily yeah no problem i don't
like something amazon prime i'm hungry
fast food
we implement it
man i know someone's going to be
watching this and we like brother ali
you drank water and you didn't say
bismillah
bro
say it in your head bro
yeah
oh yeah you you're right man
and
um i'm i'm still a new reaver myself
it's only been close in like 10 months
11 months
and but i can't begin to describe how
difficult it is
because like i want to do it properly
you know i want to do this properly and
like meet a woman and then go through
hawaii and do that process
but it's like do you understand how
difficult it is and you do because you
were there you were there and you you
said it perfectly but it's like man like
and then the girls that
aren't doing that like the proper proper
process
they're either revealing too much or
they're just doing too much
where it's like i'm like
this doesn't seem real to me either one
you seem like you're fake or two
this seems like it's not gonna end in
anywhere good because like it's trying
to advance to
to a place where it shouldn't advance
without the uh the proper steps that
allah has decreed
you know
yeah
where are you guys from canada
they are yeah me and romy are from
toronto when i was from uh florida but i
think you're in north carolina right now
right yeah yeah yeah
so you're in america
yes sir
you guys are canada yeah
okay so how is it i don't know how the
psychology are people there like how is
this i don't know how's the sisters
there way different way different way
different than the uk but i'll tell you
that how in what way hondo so the
clients that i have that are in the uk
right now all of them tell me that when
they come here they they're like bro
women are dressed completely different
i'm like what do you mean they're like
the women that dress modest in the uk
are like modest like real modest and
when they say modest here it's not the
same when they talk about reviewing the
women in in the west like here it's like
it's like too much they're like the
revealing women in the uk aren't even
that bad
okay
i didn't understand that break that down
what do you mean are you saying that the
way women sisters are dressed up here in
the uk
is more modest than
canada yeah like the they're saying that
the the women that are not modest in the
uk
could be comparable to the modest women
here
and uh
there could be one but
they could be compared so basically the
women that are are not dressing modest
in the uk so the immodest women in the
uk okay they're about the same visually
as the women that are modest here and
the women that are not modest in america
and canada it's like next level jahiliya
ting wow
that's a mad thing that's been that's
what i've heard nothing in canada
yeah that's canada bro i don't even know
how the us
imagine i keep to myself
so i don't really know how it is over
here
that's crazy man
yeah
it definitely is an uphill battle um i
feel like the sisters do struggle as
well they struggle in a different way uh
then guys do but i think ultimately it
stems from the same issue which is you
know the societal norms and what you
know society has been pushing yeah kind
of like fast food everything fast
delivery and all that that is how it is
unfortunately um and also the fact that
we we romanticize the idea of romance
without actually talking about what
marriage is what relationships are like
allah says in the quran that he put
between like a man a woman passionate
love and mercy right yeah you have the
passion i love down or even maybe not
even love lust right for the first six
seven months there's no mercy involved
right and i feel like nowadays everyone
has high expectations of their partner
and very little expectations of
themselves and how they're going to
treat their partner and it's because
we we live in a very individual
individualistic society everyone's
focused on what they're going to receive
and not so much focus on what they're
they're going to give or more
importantly allah and and how we give
for the sake of allah and i think that
is the real root of the issue that we're
all facing because me myself
i went through a
very devastating like uh marriage thing
gone wrong when i was like 18 19 was
actually only two years ago
but um
it feels like forever to be honest
instead but
that like that broke me down that that
like it really ruined me
in that moment alhamdulillah
after that because of that it allowed me
probably a lot like yourself it allowed
me to really see the the truth behind it
and all the mistakes that i made
so then i can you know insha'allah do it
right the the next time around so
i i really uh really do feel yeah yeah
yeah i definitely definitely i went i
went through similar stuff i went
through similar stuff very
man it was bad it was bad bro it was bad
i i can't i can't even explain to you
man it was
but i'm thinking of writing a book broth
like that's how bb's
i'm thinking i'm thinking about it i'm
not even joking bro i'm thinking of as
soon as there is a documentary i'm
thinking of writing a book yeah that's
so funny yeah bro it's it's it's above
it's mad it's it's if you
this is
yeah it's yeah man it's you have to be
very careful man very careful you're
getting to know
my thing that's what i'm going to say
[Laughter]
like after that
after i allah through that madness
allah wrote out a red carpet for me
like a full like full out not half
full red carpet bro
when i met when i met my wife bro
everything i'm telling you but
everything went so smooth
everything i cannot say to you oh there
was a hiccup there everything brother
just imagine a nice smooth road buff not
one bump you don't even one bump none
but the thing is it's allah puts you
through that test allah will test you
one of the things that i always wanted
was like to marry someone
that i'm happy with you know you know
someone that's you know
trying to be righteous you know doing
their best etc you know to me what was
close to me like if somebody said what
would you want i would say a righteous
wife somebody that i'm happy you know
somebody that i'm
pleasing to the eye to me you know
beauty is important as well but to it to
a point i'm trying to say
yeah
so yeah it's it's
you fix your affairs with allah stay
away from sins etc bro allah tests you
allah sends you these tests
once you when the permission of allah
you pass this test it's not upon you bro
there i've been in certain situations
where i'm like man i don't know i don't
know how i got out of this like it's
there's no other explanation but allah
there's no other explanation brother
zeal i'm thinking there's no way but
this is allah that god gets you out of
that when you ask for him his help
so and and if you pass that test
inshallah you know allah gives you the
best
inshallah inshallah
it's it's amazing because my sheikh he
was actually telling us um a few weeks
ago
that since allah is perfect
all his decisions are perfect because if
there's a decision allah made that
part of me that's deep carry on yeah so
if allah makes a decision that's not the
most optimal then he can't be perfect
right he so he must make the perfect
decision so every single thing that
happens to you in your life is the most
perfect thing that could have happened
even if it's you walking and you hit
your elbow on the table or something
that's actually the most perfect thing
that could have happened to you in that
moment and subhanallah if you
if you link this event right i can only
use a personal example that like
engagement whatever gone wrong
to all the future events you'll come to
find that these wouldn't exist if this
didn't exist and who you are today
wouldn't be who you are if this didn't
happen so yeah 100
things yeah
100 bro i
i speak to my wife and i'm like if i
didn't go through that i would have
ruined our marriage
wow i tell you i tell you if i didn't go
through that i know me what would ruin
our marriage now really marriage like i
know i might have been ungrateful i know
i know i've appreciated you i might have
not valued you if i didn't go through
that i tell her i'm like you know what
i'm thinking if that was me that owed me
i would have ruined our marriage
you know so the thing is it's that's why
i know
i had to go through that because allah
knows you allah knows you he had to put
me through that it was hell
hell bro like like you you got shaking
you know when allah says the sahaba was
shaken yeah and i'm not saying i
wouldn't i'm not saying i'm saying like
you're shaking bro and allah says that i
think it's talking about the battle of
khanda where they started to think about
allah all sorts of things
all sorts of things go through your mind
you're in that zone where like all kinds
of stuff going through your head i'm
trying to say but the thing is after
that you know the you know they say you
know what allah and his messenger
promises came true
you know so it's it's it's like that but
you said you was engaged yeah another
topic that we discuss
in the marriage documentary and the app
is um this is not related to you by the
way yeah i don't want you to feel like
i'm it's not this thing because we're
talking about massive engagement it's
very important we have a topic called
engaged in haram yeah um so basically
in my marriage journey
um i've come across you know i've met a
lot of sisters for marriage yeah when i
mean a lot like it's normal you know we
meet they didn't work out i was looking
for a long time
so obviously sometimes you hear stories
you know etc but the thing is it's and
this is even seeking marriage and
alzheimer's so sometimes sisters come
for advice and this happened that
happened we interviewed two sisters in
the documentary one attempted suicide
two we're going to attempt it one no two
um there was suicidal one attempted it
yeah and it was because of this they
were engaged
yeah see what happens if shaytan comes
to you yeah are you engaged now you're
gonna get married two months left
guards down and the shaytan comes and
boom punches you right in the nose yeah
no anywhere else right on the nose bang
because the thing is now you have let
your cards down why because families
have met
you booked the wedding hall
the dress or the clothes aboard that
you're thinking you're in your head what
are you doing you're logically thinking
logically thinking
what could go wrong nothing
booked booked booked holiday booked
everything book book
so in your head you're thinking nice
calm it's all right you know if i hold
your hand and one day you're going out
together maybe the families it's in this
issue with the families as well you know
um yeah guys you guys go you know it's
very dangerous you guys go yeah you know
man a woman brother man and woman is is
it it's you don't mix them together
that's that's like petrol and fire it's
as simple as that no i know above you
can be
sheikh bin baz
you can be an alim yeah i think it was
he said he's he said i'm like what
60 years old or something like that he
goes the most thing that i fear for
myself is a woman he's like 60 above
he's like 60 plus brother yeah so the
thing is this is that we don't
we don't understand that and what
happened is zina happens and then
you can think logically but you see how
did shaytan fall he took his akl over
the knuckle how did this happen allah
told him to bow down to adam
this is the knuckle this is the text
allah is telling this the spirit of
allah saying bow down to adam correct
yeah
what did shaytan what cause shaytan to
be misguided he used his acl he said
okay let me think logically
bow down to something made out of clay
no
i'm better than him
logic logically thinking i'm better than
him why would i bow down to something
i'm better than off the point is this
allah to do something
you hear and you obey yes when allah and
his messenger makes a decision you
khalas
so what did he do he said no logically
i'm better than him
and then i know there's rocks
i think box with him about imagine if
i'm not mistaken where he shows that
actually clay is better than fire the
point is this that logically he thought
nah i'm better than him and no i'm not
going to and he didn't fall into
disbelief because he didn't bow down
he fell into disbelief because he
ascribed the mistake to allah he's
basically saying to allah you're wrong
how could you tell me to do something
that's wrong
i'm trying to say so that's that's why a
lot of the times we use our logic in
that sense i'm not saying there's
nothing wrong you can use allah you use
you know thing but the point is
certain things allah says the process of
said when a man and a woman is alone the
further shaytan
no logic is out the window i don't care
if you come and say to me this man has
zero sexual desires
irrelevant brother did allah say so
messenger says that's all i need to
know and on that term bro
i was literally talking to the sister
today and she asked me
like how do i do it now because again
i'm a new reaver uh beforehand i had
started doing this thing called
you heard
uh oh is it like um
you tell me
bro it's basically what a muslim is
supposed to do like a muslim man not
supposed to uh
you know
supposed to do any of that stuff okay
not supposed to watch
right and then of course islam takes it
a step further and says don't even have
this relationship just you know focus on
yourself
do this uh properly here right so i got
into nofap then uh me i was engaged
before coming to islam
uh me and this girl ended up splitting i
decided not to have
or any relationship for several years
then i become muslim and this girl was
asking me like how do i do it now as
like a a reaver to where like i'm not
putting myself at the uh i'm just not
doing zinna i'm not coming to xeno right
and i was like it's very easy i just i
keep to myself
i don't i barely even speak to
random people and i know that sounds
messed up but even people who who uh you
wouldn't say the believers
or you know i have no idea if they are
or not but i just i don't even speak to
other dudes because it just leads to
free mixing
if they're not muslim themselves
you know and and it all it all connects
what we're saying here yeah exactly you
know at the end of the day
we have trigger points you know if you
have things that you know even like on
instagram bro you can't even go on
explore page i can't go on explore page
on my instagram i don't because when i
go there brother all these sisters caked
up even hijab some of them aki wallahi
i know it's
and it's in your face you just go on
explore page boom a video right in front
of your face yeah and you're thinking
bro you can't explore sometimes i've got
an explore page because i see like good
reminders and i want to reshare it i
can't even go there bro i can't even go
there
let me let me tell you what shaytan did
he put the search place in the explore
page like you got to click on that
explorer to kick the search
yeah yeah exactly and even when
searching but if you're searching for a
friend's name
ahmed a h and then you see some next
level um some girl called ahia or
whatever she called uh i'm just making
it make it up
you can't even search the guys you have
to write the full name before he comes
up other than that you've got all these
mad stuff coming up
yeah yeah that's true
so with that being said how did you meet
your wife
i mean that's a personal question you
have to watch the documentary for that
my um yeah man you need to watch man
because
the documentary is like this let me
start from here one second right to the
end
there we go yeah documentary starts off
like this high aspirations yes i'm going
to get married i'm going to get married
no i'm not getting married
no no
ali don't give up don't give up yep just
going good oh i think she's the one
she's the one boom no she's not the one
she's the one she's the one she's the
one hundred percent she's the one show
your p show her pictures to your mom my
mom likes it yes definitely happened
boom didn't happen
you know how many times i've got there
yep yep that's the one it's got to be
this one it's a sign from allah
boom no that's not the one oh it's this
sister yes we spoke a couple of years
ago yes you know your family caused a
bit of an issue yeah yeah yeah yeah
okay bye bye
it's like that bro bang bang there
and then hit rock bottom and now i go to
your screen yeah i'm in your screen now
i'm already at the bottom here
and then
eventually you come up i come out your
screen then i go to i go to ramy then i
go to the fires page then i come back
all the way from the sky here and then
somewhere here i found my wife
but there it was it was interesting when
i when i met my wife this was what i'll
tell you when i met my wife yeah
in a matter
the platform that we met
in a matter of
three hours that we were speaking
that i spoke to her dad and i thought it
was a scam because i've been catfished
before yeah so in a matter of three
hours
i said i said and me
because i said there's certain things
that i need to go and know about the
sister yeah and i discuss this with
people of knowledge it's not coming from
me yeah i would say okay
i need to know some basic stuff about
her i can't if i go and say can i speak
to your dad okay i'll speak to that
immediately hello
yes okay uh uncle i want to speak i want
to get to know the door for marriage
okay no problem um he says okay me up
and you the first thing me up okay um i
would like you to um i don't know
argument's sake um you have to win the
cup oh i don't want to wear in a cup i
don't believe it's first oh we're not
compatible so i went to the dad
yeah spoke and the first meeting we're
not compatible or this that or i don't
whatever it may be the point is you are
allowed to ask some basic questions just
so you know you're just on the same same
page with a few stuff and i'm talking
about a matter of speaking let's say a
couple of hours maximum a day and but
you are intention is look i want to
speak to your dad right after this if
you're compatible i want to speak to
that or your wally immediately yeah
that's at least you asking basic
questions just that's just to get the
hassle out the way of you know so a
disclaimer i'm not asking anyone
watching this brother ali said yeah you
can go no one's what i'm saying is you
can get to know basic stuff would you
like to work um would you like kids you
want to stay here just some basic basic
basic questions so you know okay well
there's some compatibility there now
dad immediately so with me
sometimes certain sisters would take
ages like introducing a wally oh you
know my dad's abroad okay
i'll wait let's wait for dr.com so the
thing is with her it was like
immediately bro within a matter of a
couple of hours
she gave me a dad's number and i was
thinking lah this is a scam brother i
said oh man there's a scam and i thought
he's going to get one of her cousins to
answer or something like that so i
called
and i hear uncle uncle voice
and i was like
and he's like yeah my
said the door's name uh said about you
may allah bless you you know for coming
and talking to me oh i was well i was i
couldn't believe my and he was talking
talking and he's like yeah i'll give my
approval
and he was he was just talking and bro
he was so jolly and i was like
like to me it was like i couldn't
believe it like it was a proper uncle
and it was very
you see when allah
has accepted something and the time is
right things happen so smooth and so
fast
they have been so smooth and so fast so
not that you're trying but
because sometimes when you're getting to
know a sister and you really want it to
happen
you try oh come on i'm going to make it
work listen let's get my hands camera
quickly you're trying and it doesn't
work and it doesn't work and it doesn't
work with this it's as if allah is just
he's just if someone just lifted you up
from your feet and everything is
happening in front of you so it happened
very fast
very very fast we got married
within three months i think two months
two or three months here
within two or three months bro when i
like met her
um to my mummy you know my mom
i had a bad experience and after i had
that bad experience my mom was on my
case my mom was like you're you're
you're gonna listen to us you know after
you went for that bad experience
um and you're you're gonna stick to
you're gonna marry a turkish girl yeah
so and i was like oh man you know i
don't mind i don't mind there's nothing
with turkish sisters etc but i was
thinking where am i gonna find them
because in the uk it is quite hard i'm
curt there is an issue between the turks
and kurds anyways and then we have the
whole sunni my family's back uh
background halloween and so there was a
lot of elements and i was thinking i
don't know in my search i've never come
across turkish sisters and i don't know
and i went turkey i went turkey looking
just saw my mom's happy
couldn't find anything so i and then
when i told my mom about
my wife and she was like no look what i
told you look you know i said mom just
me please i've got like a video footage
in my documentary i tell her look just
meet her yeah it's in my documentary i'm
in the car with her i'm like just meet
her just saying
i don't know this that bro i took her to
the restaurant went to the restaurant my
wife came with her sister and her friend
yeah so my mom she's coming so this is
my mom yeah the restaurant they're
coming from the door so mom's like this
which one is it which one is it yeah and
then she and i'm like that one there
she's looking she's looking she's
looking looking looking looking looking
she comes hello they hug she sits down
and my mom goes i like her
straight away is that her yeah i like
her
do you get it bro she's just observing
like uh she came sat down this is her
yeah okay i like her
and my mom but my mom can be judgmental
mom looks nah
you know zeeshan's a bit like that
nishan we're going to go and do that
with today ah nah that's dead man
zeshan leave your couch and come to the
park
uh i don't know the weather's a bit dead
yeah
so the thing is my mom was sometimes a
bit apprehensive so with that when that
happened i was like whoa that was mad to
me that was like come on bro like
anything that can go wrong and even like
my dad
my dad sometimes like no you know um
because like me man wanted to marry a
hijabi because my dad's a bit you know
hostile towards islam is he's a bit
better now but i've had my issues so the
thing is even my dad my dad was like no
i'm not coming to you i'm not coming to
your wedding
yeah my mother's gonna imagine my dad's
saying i'm not like i'm not coming to
your wedding i'm not coming and and
imagine we're doing the nikah in the
masjid yeah well mother's not coming to
know masjid but i've never gone to a
masjid yeah
bro my dad turns up in the masjid
with my uncle
and my uh cousin
in the masjid he's in the masjid
and my dad to this day
he's very hostile towards islam don't
think it's ving he came to the masjid
bro he came to the masjid and my
teachers reading dua my dad hates that
stuff bro my dad's just he was just
there
he was there he was just
well it was it was so um
thing that i can remember when i came
the the the the culture that i married
into they have a tradition
uh i won't go into the tradition because
they'll give it away because a lot of
people are very like where's ali tao's
wife from you know so the thing is it's
they have a tradition so
i i had something missing
and then my dad came to the rescue broth
wow
the ball is like and it was peak i was
like oh my gosh how did i forget that
and it was just bro even that moment was
a little hiccup bro like that it got
resolved in what uh 20 minutes
wow 20 minutes
i'll see what you're doing bro you're
trying to
get people wet bro
that sounds a bit wrong but okay
exactly right brother
i mean if you're meaning that yes yeah
we're trying to make it rainier
yeah yeah yeah you know keep it alive
bro yeah make sure they have umbrellas
there we go there we go side question
but let's say you were single today how
do you dis differentiate between a girl
that actually wants you for you
versus a fame digger
that's interesting i have a whole um
part in my mind of course
i got everything you tell me anything
it's covered in the documentary anything
brother anything
that part i've got this is a chapter
called the ali dawa factor
i talk about all the sisters i've got to
know got to know for marriage but they
were interested like more of who i am
um
who i am who i really are they're
interested in what you are not who you
are yes so that's why i call it the
alidah factor uh because um i would get
to know this is for marriage and i can
see the young um they're
yani i'm not blaming them but it's it's
a hype it's ali you want you want to
marry me so you can go to your family
members and say oh i'm married
and then after a few months when you
realize that ali dao is not who you
think he is in the context where you
know i don't know if you think some
people think i'm rich or something i
don't know like when you realize that
you know i'm running with a toyota prius
yeah you know when sometimes it's
peaking i'm doing that i'm coming home
late you know sometimes all kind of mad
stuff can happen you know police can
turn up the donut because i'm doing
anything illegal but you know telling me
you know how you just had a death threat
mate you know we just need to let you
know so when you realize all that kind
of stuff and you're like whoa man i
didn't sign up for this yeah you signed
up for something that is what you saw
so i would call it that added a fact and
people coming to me oh it must be so
easy for you to get married i'm not
really brother why is it taking me so
long you know people think oh you know
look at you you know you're not
necessarily ugly or really handsome are
you okay looking you've got the fame you
know you look like
i said bro if allah doesn't will it
comes back to tahit if allah doesn't
will but i can be a millionaire i can be
the most handsome guy i can have
everything if allah doesn't will i would
have girls but i would never have a wife
that's what people don't understand
that's why i called it the ali dawa
factor because the people what people
need to understand it's in allah's hands
it's not who you are brother
in our app that we're doing there's a
brother that we interview called jody
he's a revert to islam may allah bless
him he has a disability where he can't
walk yeah
the guy has memorized the quran yeah he
was rejected a few times he married a
sister he married a somali sister he has
three kids now yeah
if i was to and i'm giving an example
beautiful brother if we was to get
compare someone
like him argument's sake here and a
footballer we will see who is more
likely to get married everyone will
point out the footballer everybody
muslims who believe should point out at
him you know why because if allah wills
it doesn't matter what you have who you
are if allah wills you will get married
it's in allah's hands the one who's
created the heavens and the earth is
hard for him to get find someone to
marry you really really the one who's
created the whole galaxy and the
universe is hard for him to find you a
wife really or a husband
the question is you need to ask yourself
a question i'm trying to say
i knew there was two obstacles stopping
me before i met my wife there was two
sins that i was committing yeah i want
to say they were major but there was two
sins that was committing that
i should i should have stopped
and once i realized that i had two
options either
i was i was in a state of why is allah
doing this to me why why i'm staying
away from zina i do uber i pick up
certain girls who try to float me in the
car but i don't want that i don't want
that life i'm trying to say i fear for
myself bro i'm a man i feel like i'm
trying to say and it's by the will of
allah i'm trying to say you have these
girls coming and flowing with you trying
to touch you
i'm trying to say i don't want that bro
i want to be exposed to that kind of
stuff you know and you're begging allah
protect me you protect me because it's
not matter like yusuf al islam in the
quran allah says if it wasn't for our
signs he may have inclined to it may
have like
they might
say it's with allah's permission people
need to understand even yusuf ali
islam's thing is not of who you suffer
islam is it's because of allah subhanahu
salah otherwise ibrahim alayhi wouldn't
say allah protect us from shirk you're
the prophet of allah protect you
from your brother it's all connected to
allah and this is what people don't
understand it's it's it's all in the
hands of allah and once you put your
tawakkum and trust in him you won't need
to go and show your hijab and dress up
in tight brothers you don't need to go
and sell drugs to provide you what i'm
trying to say brothers i need to play
maghrib um
we can continue or we can do
this up to you
yeah i'm good to continue man
okay let's go let's pray margaret and
then um we can do another 20 25 minutes
we can even do part two no problem any
time but let's lean in pray inshallah
inshallah give give us an estimate of
how long it will take yeah no no no
about six six minutes six seven minutes
take your time and take your time make
sure this is in this make sure this is
in the video yeah yeah
they need to see this bro you need to
see this have you paid yourself brothers
yeah
sometimes i say have you played uh
maghrib but you might be in a different
country no we we played ourselves in an
hour and a half he's asking the viewers
bro wherever you're watching it
whatever it is make sure you pray
yourself we're going to be back wait for
me
all right i actually have to pray as
well so i'll be back go ahead bro
go for it
all right are you going to start the
recording uh
are you gonna keep it recording
no i'm gonna keep recording so it's 1.5
all right man what are your thoughts so
far and what was talked
it's a big tease bro
but it's very enlightening it's very
annoying because it's it's showing me
[Music]
it's showing me a few things that i've
been kind of like
things that i should be getting past and
i'm not gonna air my sins i'm not gonna
say what it is
that i'm doing but like
it i have seen it and i've been slowly
working at it alhamdulillah
allah has been allowing me to progress
and
get further and further in this
but it's like i'm
exactly what i'm doing is exactly what
he's saying so it's like it's for me i
can say
it's like confirmation
i would do the same thing too bro
you already use that huh you're already
married though not about that bro just
about
the whole energy the whole vibe
everything he was saying it was
something that just affirmed something
that i'm currently
reflecting on
you know what i mean
like when he talked about just trusting
in the will of
allah yeah
yeah
100
but um i have a question that i want to
ask him
i definitely have a question
and i'll say here because um if anything
you can help me out remind me if my mind
goes blank you know what my mind is
uh but basically
with what he was saying you know he at
first he said the the thing that we have
all
you know said to each other in private
which is you know you tie your camel
and then you put or you know you you
have faith in allah and then you tie
your camel
right
so i believe it's tired camel and have
faith in allah yeah okay okay so
having faith in a lot that's making dua
that's like doing your part and getting
closer to allah and what you're doing
like what he's saying
but now
tying the camel what does time the camel
consist of in this situation as a a
muslim man that's seeking to get married
you know like that's what i'm interested
in you you talking about what we're
supposed to do or what we're not
supposed to do
in terms of time
i know what we suppose
what we're not supposed to do i'm
talking about what are we
what are we going to do here like what
is tying the camera what is the
equivalent of timing i got you i don't
know what you is he is he going to the
masjid and like
having a shake pimp you out
is it uh
it's definitely not going on these
websites he even said that the website
didn't work
see 15 years ago it was different you
know
you'd go to the museum every day for
fudger
and
seven day in a week
some uncle stops you by and says hey man
i seen you coming every single day
mashallah you know you look good what do
you do
ten minutes in the conversation he's
like you know what i have a daughter
that
is uh you know that i'm trying to marry
are you interested
that's how easy it would be back then
bro
not today it ain't that easy now
no
but it is important to have have trust
in allah like uh
brother ali said that's not his real
name though i know i know
you know what i'm wondering though i i
used to always wonder how how he was
born um you know he was kurt but he
wasn't muslim like he was a reaver
right but subhanallah man like i thought
he was a born muslim we'll see nah i
knew he was a river i knew he was a
reaper from his videos yeah
i mean you can't yes he has his reverse
story
yeah but i thought he meant like weaver
in the sense that me and ramy consider
ourselves you know like we came on dean
later in our life but you can't tell bro
like how many people nine out of nine
people would look at gabriel today and
be like yo this guy's a born muslim bro
yeah come on now come on no one's gonna
know he used to be a romanian you know
and now he's he's a convert and martial
man that's the beauty of the song
i love blessing bro
i mean i mean
yeah
but man like i've been told word of
mouth
what a mouth to to get a wife or like
ask people that you know to ask people
that they know and it's like well i've
done that
and that hasn't worked and then the fact
that i i'm like
i keep to myself there ain't many people
that i can reach out to and be like yo
i'm trying to get married do you know
anyone that's also trying to get married
you feel me
i know you're feeling bright i ain't
even gotta ask i do know but like bro
let me ask you something right and guys
if for any reason you are seeing this
which i highly doubt because i usually
cut these parts out but if we did put it
up and you guys like these little
segways comment down below hashtag
intermission and we'll keep it uncut
but my guy if it's too personal you
don't have to answer it do you want to
share with the viewers what you have
shared with me about that one time that
you were talking to a sister and it
didn't work out
you talking about
talking about that
are you talking about the one that uh
yeah just saying what you're saying i'm
just saying bro i know i know what we're
thinking she was a hijabi
and then she sent me a picture like of
her with her hair
nah i wasn't talking about that bro oh
damn bro i was talking about the one
where uh it was the texting thing and
there was a friend in the group chat
oh yeah that that didn't really work out
but there's no reason to put on blasts
or nothing no no there's no names just
say what happened
oh okay yeah so
i was put into this chat
and what do you mean you were put into
this chat bro put into this chat by a
friend a dear friend
okay
and when i was put into this chat it was
the girl and then her friend
her friend was acting like a supervisor
and i was like you know what like that's
all right i don't mind i don't mind that
at all it'll keep him more a lot
and
she has said assalamu alaikum
but then i got busy so i didn't respond
back for like two days
and by this by the first day
the girl that i was supposed to be
talking to left the group chat
and then by the second date her friend
had messages on the group chat and was
like
oh i hope you have a good excuse i'm
like subhanallah
like i can't be busy bro like i gotta be
on top and like be messaging back like
24 7.
but um yeah not to throw dirt on them
but it's like
i don't know i don't even know why why
you had me say that bro
what was the point
maybe because
if you had a little bit more patience it
could have worked out
but then again
but then again the fact that it didn't
work out it wasn't the one anyway yeah
that's [ __ ] but you talking about the
girl cuz i didn't leave the group chat
no that's true that's true
your boy was just busy
she got pretty butt hurt about that one
yeah yeah yeah i mean think about it she
was is she bro she was gonna get butt
hurt about that that early imagine your
marriage bro you didn't take out the
garbage i told you five seconds ago to
take out the garbage you know you
grabbed the garbage bag
[Laughter]
that was that was strictly for
entertainment purposes guys
yeah don't be don't come on now you guys
are ridiculous sometimes with your
presuppositions and assumptions about
romney's joke it's a joke guys relax
you meant take it and like throw it
through the window in the garbage bin
that's what you get yeah exactly like
he's like hey baby
how quick i did that next time i'm gonna
aim for three seconds and stuff yeah
yeah yeah ramen you like that form yeah
nice and crispy yeah yeah yeah there we
go
three point that's a three-pointed form
la shall
jump shot one more thing bro
the viewers know this too it's not
confirmed but i was just bumping some
ideas out with on her last night on the
phone
we might in a few months insha'allah if
allah wills
quick meet and greet a lot of our uh
guests we had so far on the epis on the
podcast they want to see us
and we'll make it happen inshallah it
just depends on me for all the people
that are watching for all the people
that live in the uk
that want to like i don't know i guess
meet us
i don't know why they would want to meet
us it's not like we're famous or nothing
we're just three real brothers you know
yeah yeah but we should do something
like that too to meet everyone who's uh
watching and supporting the channel see
i was gonna say no to me and greet but i
looked at our analytics the other night
and we got a lot of viewers from the uk
bro yeah
the uk muslim scene is
unreal bro martial
it's i think i think it's really strong
because the daddy's there are strong i
was thinking about it um
i i kept hearing that there's two kinds
of like
two things that are two types of
obligations there's obligation
upon the individual and the obligation
upon the community now this is the thing
let's take dawah for an example if there
are enough people giving dawa they
satisfy the obligatory portion the
obligation upon the community but if
there isn't enough
uh dawah then it's obligatory upon every
single individual of the community to
come forward to fix that
and if no one does the entire community
is sinful for that
so i feel like they're they're their
daddies are so strong you know you have
adidas
on you have like all these people it's
very strong
and you can see
two things one they have they have a
strong push against islam so that gives
birth to a lot of daisy who strongly
enforce islam and strongly push islam
and give that one right we don't have
that kind of strong intention against
islam in in canada and even in america
it's not as bad so we don't have the
strong the strong that ease right but in
sha allah us three and everyone else we
have to push forward to satisfy that
obligation for the community and then
insha'allah will be just as strong and
shot a lot stronger i mean
exactly exactly
and then there's duad which are the pool
right yeah yeah
you were using that for plural bro
my bad man
i didn't bro i was like bro i got your
message bro there's some ocd guy in the
back just punching the air right now
but it's important bro grammar
especially in arabic is really important
yeah i see the camera turned back on but
what is that
with a horror movie now yeah
guys we're joined for some uh backstage
uh vip access into ali dawa's room
i think it's funny because like we said
that that's like the famous couch in the
beginning
i mean as rami said welcome back to the
next episode of alidawah after dark
yes now it's about to get
any kids watching this please switch off
i mean bro your camera's just done
it was the lights not the camera
okay
[Music]
all right
cops the cops are here corrupt cops
[Laughter]
yeah that's the sean we don't have a pig
in there
[Music]
all right
all right i think it's only fair that
once we get rolling on how to ask this
question that he had on his mind yes yes
bro so we'll continue uh so you started
off saying that you tie your camel and
then you have
faith in allah yeah all right so with
everything you said you were saying that
uh you know you you make dua
don't underestimate the power of dua get
closer to allah um
get more deeper into your deen you know
take care of what you got to take care
of and then allah will provide so
that would be the equivalent of having
the faith in allah but now
tying the camel what would be the
equivalent of time to camo for a
young muslim brother who's looking to
get married in today's day and age if
he's taken care of the other aspect
well he needs to see what does he define
as taking care of the other aspect what
is how do you take care of it because a
lot of people say it's interesting i've
got cop in my hand as well
people say it's um
completing half of your deen
yeah
the issue is with this is because we
need to bear in mind
when you're completing half of your deen
yeah that means you the hot cup the cup
is half full meaning your dean is there
and what you're fitting up is the
marriage side which means you will
complete your deen
a lot of the times today a cup is empty
and they want to complete the other half
baba there's not even a the glass is not
half full how are you completing the
other half there is no deen what do you
mean complete the other half by the way
do you pray salah no
okay this girl are you like what are you
going about halal away no you're in a
home relationship okay
brother do you fast in ramadan yeah i'll
try
okay
what's that
brother are you talking about you need
to complete half your deen meaning the
deen is there and you're completing the
other half if this is empty how are you
completing the other half and the
problem this is the problem you know you
need to make sure that your first
priority is you
praying salah doing your bit giving the
rights of allah you know fix your
affairs with allah allah will fix your
affairs with the people and your whole
affairs at home at large so make sure
that you're given the rights of allah
once you understand and do that
the this is that's why the prophet peace
be upon him said one of the most
powerful things for a believer it's his
dua you know once you give allah's
rights you stay away from sins you're
very careful
for the stuff that you do and try your
best because allah says indeed with
hardship comes ease
verily with hardship comes these so
practicing the dean might be hard
it might be hard but let me tell you
something you are going to face hardship
regardless
don't think the other this believer
there is having a child life he's going
through hardship as well you have a menu
that will help you through these
hardships we're all in the forest we're
in that all in the jungle we're going to
be bit tree's going to drop on our head
yeah what kind of mass stuff are going
to happen you have a manual that will
help you get out of there some people
don't and they get stuck under the tree
yeah so the thing is
fix your face with allah with the deen
make sure the dean is on point then now
you can look for the other half if
everyone focused on their deen
yeah if everyone that's the reason why
for example look if everyone told their
children their sons and their daughters
how to behave how men should respect
women not oh she's moving around like uh
you know i don't know what the terms i
don't use like you know these loose
girls yeah or she's moving like a loose
girl so i'm going to treat her meaning
she's up for zina i'm going to i'm going
to give her i'm going to treat her like
that what the hell are you talking about
are you a muslim what are you if you're
a muslim you should fear allah and again
i talk and brother i'm going to come to
your point if i go off please come back
i'm sorry i'm going on a tangent here in
my documentary i had a point
where i discussed this and it's
dedicated i think it's part three or two
it's dedicated to men
it's dedicated to brothers because when
i remember i told you guys i was on a
matrimonial app in 2013 when i first
came to islam yeah
actually there were girls that would
link up and while they were they were
forgive me but they were offering me
dinner
click out
and they were literally
i'm not going to come and say they were
saying oh let's have but they were in a
nutshell
yanny you know if you come from a
jahalia you know when the girl's on it
yeah
so
i had to correct them
i could have gone with the flow i could
have gone with the floor and say yeah no
problem bro i left that lifestyle that
disgusting filthy lifestyle behind yeah
and it made me sick to my stomach to
know that i'm
facing this with my new whole and a new
page in my life and i'm facing this yeah
i would have to correct these girls i'm
not trying to sound holy here but i
would have to say to them you know some
of them
didn't wear the hijab some of them
observed the hijab some of them newly
aware in the hijab
um and
it would shock me when i would hear this
and i would say you know like and i
would be a bit harsh let me be real yeah
i was very harsh with them i was so
harsh bro when i would see like a muslim
woman hijab no hijab newlywed
to me i was so disturbed by it that i
would literally flip on them
i would say like
i've come here for marriage
and you're here basically if i give you
the permission
you're oh you're all over me man
and i'll say like i would have to tell
them like fear allah like what you get
it and that is every man's duty as a
believer if a woman
for example bro some there's an instance
that happened that i discussed in my
documentary a specific sister was going
for a specific issue whatever it may be
and whatever it may be she just wanted
to move on you know when you go through
a crisis you know it's called bounce i
think what's the codemap for the word
rebound rebound rebound yeah
all right
rebound he's playing basketball um so
it's rebound so what they happen is they
want to get over it forget about it so
some madness yes you probably just but
the thing is
she
she was calling me to something which is
not permissible so i said sister i said
fear allah yeah i said i'm actually
disgusted i said i don't like i was
harsh
but the limiter is something my sister
contacted me two years later
and said thank you for keeping me in
check
because i was in a bad place
and you could have take full advantage
of me and i was allowing that
but you put me in check
now the thing is i'm not trying to sound
holy i'm not trying to sound like i'm
some but the point is this if every
muslim man behaves in this manner rather
than thinking oh she's moving loose
brother let me just use an abuser and
i'm trying to say you as a believer
should if the girl doesn't know the
she's going about the wrong way you have
to pull not literally and put on the
right path and say no sister feel allah
not about that life i respect you as a
person somebody else's sister before all
of that allah says this is haram yeah
out of my respect
you need to put her in check
i'm trying to say oh she puts you in
check you can be vice versa as well
before the feminists get onto me yeah
like oh you know you know so the thing
is
coming back to the whole dean aspect aki
is that you need to make sure that you
don't check and if all of us did this
aki while he we wouldn't have to go
around advising one another if all of us
advise our sons and our daughters our
sons how to lower the gays on observe
themselves and our systems how to
correct the hijab if everyone focused in
their house wallahi
community as a large will be amazing
because everyone is focused in their
house and if everyone's corrected their
self in their house when they come
outside everyone's wearing a corrected
job brothers are observing themselves in
the right way everyone is fixed upon but
what we're doing now is because that's
not happening we have to come and advise
this person and then advise that person
that is wrong you shouldn't do that i'm
trying to say that's what allah says
save yourself and your family from the
fire first so as long as you start from
yourself and correct yourself aki allah
will send someone inshallah befitting to
you so you give the rights of allah and
then
observe and don't forget allah will test
you don't think i'm going to get closer
to allah and then allah is going to give
me someone no i can say to you i i did
that and i went through some peak times
i was questioning like what's like
what's going on like i was like what the
hell is going on like i'm trying my best
to stay away and etc but it's getting
harder and harder and i'm finding
someone to get married like what does
allah want from me like i had the
moments of light i was like what's going
on but the thing is i had a deeper
reflection and i understood there are
certain things that i was doing wrong
and i had to fix them and i made dua i
said oh allah you know i really made dua
i said allah help me i have no one but
you help me and allah will help allah
will help there's no way allah will not
help you fear allah says you fear me i
will give you a way out from places you
can't you'll never imagine
i don't ask you a question i did what
was the question like yeah
it reminds me of the verse in the quran
where it says uh remember me and i will
remember you yeah yeah exactly something
like that yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm doing
that
but um it's more so like okay let's say
your brother has
that in check and they're they're
actively doing that
like you obviously wouldn't advise them
to go on some website or something like
that
to try to get i didn't advise them going
to a website yeah because see i've had
why not what website what's like like a
matrimony type like uh
like the stuff that you were into in the
beginning because it obviously didn't
work out it was obviously like nothing
but
basically you had um sleep no no but the
thing is no no but the thing is
because it didn't work out it's not
because the platform was the issue
now there's a thin line there are some
apps that are not necessarily permiss
like i wouldn't call them fully halal
but they work i know a lot of people
that got married
it does work
it's about you you can't i'm trying to
say you need to know yourself so go into
this app
you know you know yourself if you know
you're going to be dragged into haram
stay away from bro you know yourself
best and that can happen anyway that can
have an instagram bro you don't need to
be on an app that can happen on
instagram on facebook that can happen in
your house buff that can happen outside
so the thing is as long as you know
yourself
um
just go and try bro go into the apps try
the apps but it depends what app yeah
some of them are booty full out buki you
know when you go on this app and you're
looking like they're what's their bloody
um the the the about us bit yeah dating
they don't get that i'll be above what
i'm trying to say so it depends what it
is but i would say test to see okay let
me see is it working there might be a
good sister that might this might be the
means you know it happens
it happens so don't don't negate
anything
try your best all avenues through
friends i went through that through
friends through um not family because i
don't know anyone in my family i went
through friends etc
um i went for i tried instagram i
messaged when i'm in instagram there was
if i came across a sister that i find a
liking in i would message i'll mention
this i'm gonna come to my intentions i'm
looking to get mad if you're interested
if not ignore this message
call us
try don't don't just be that sick try
brother go to marriage event go to a
marriage event
you see a sister in the masjid go ask
somebody to ask on your behalf
facebook if you see someone add up with
a good ad up approaching you i'm trying
to say if i don't know if you're on the
road you have your sister to say this
sister so can you go ask for my behalf
just try your bit man do your bit you
can't continuously have to do your bit
yeah
his approach is so refreshing isn't it
it's like get your own affairs in check
and then don't worry about the rest yeah
yeah it's like the acumen a lot look
that's why i said to myself when when i
realized the two sins i was committing
and i i started i focused on stopping
them you know i said to myself i really
question myself i said ali think about
it yeah
is it really look you believe in allah
okay you believe allah created heavens
and the earth you believe allah has
created jannah and na and angels and all
this kind of stuff is it hard for allah
to send your wife no one lie i said to
my impossible i said there's something
i'm doing wrong
it has to be me i can't point out i have
to say there's something you're doing
wrongly and i knew i said that's when i
went to
you know when you sieve it out i
wouldn't say that there's these two
things i'm committing and you know these
two things they're going to have an
effect on my marriage if i carry on so i
said okay i need to work on these sins
these one even no matter how minor or
major you have to work on them and i
worked on them alhamdulillah
eventually
i'm trying to say so it's it's it's you
will realize there's something that
allah is trying to tell you you get it
you might not see it
allow me to see it you know even the
fact that one acknowledges sin is a
blessing from allah the fact that these
people who don't know what's him but i
don't come in he says oh masha allah you
know the guy's swimming in sins but he
thinks he's er
i'm trying to say so reflect what is it
that i'm doing wrong what's allah trying
to tell me you know am i doing something
wrong you have to reflect
subhanallah one of the biggest issues
that i see in a lot of the youth today
is they have a pee addiction bro just
watching and and doing more than just
watching sometimes
addiction because it might get the
amount oh yeah yeah yeah
but let you know they do that and that
that directly is something in and of
itself that will reflect in your
marriage too so what advice would you
have to uh brothers and sisters that are
suffering from that
look i don't know if i can have any
advice on that i don't know if there's
anything practical that i know
um but this app that we're developing
once again we have professionals who
deal with this the reason you see ak is
so important because what happened
addiction
it's that aki you're watching something
which is not real it's like watching
superman and going to the tall building
and saying allahu akbar and
you know janazah yeah okay i'm going to
do janaz i pray over you
the thing is what you're doing is you're
looking at something that is not real
it's special effects and then you are
going and expecting the same results
you're doing the same thing you're
wearing the cape superman he done it
what did he say before he jumps i don't
know
what does superman say before i jump did
you say anything probably doesn't say
anything yeah
yeah
and the thing is you're doing it and
you're looking oh but actually why
didn't it work because brother that's
not real so when you're watching
you are watching something that is not
real and
it destroys your soul aki
it's like imagine you have a round ball
full of sharp knives inside you
shredding you into pieces shredded like
smashing you into pieces
and finish you it would finish you you
have false expectations yeah when you
i feel sorry for you there is no sister
on this planet that's gonna reach your
criteria it doesn't exist you're gonna
be looking for a sister that doesn't
exist and not only that
every woman that you look at
every woman bob you go you go coffee
shop and you look at you like you look
at the waitress god knows what goes for
your head you go to your school and you
see a hijabi god knows what fetish goes
for your head you are a
you're literally
excuse me you're literally like
you're you're it's like your stuff i
don't want to use it you r-a-p-i-n-g
they're correct
yeah yeah not r-a-p-v they'll be rapping
yeah
so bro you're literally doing that to
all of them with your eyes
this is what you're doing and if if yeah
subhanallah men our biggest weakness is
women can you imagine brother you're
giving yourself a turbo boost when
you're watching
the normal fitter alas created that with
your
your um imagine a wheel attire it can go
let's say 120 miles an hour imagine you
put that tire on a thousand miles an
hour it's gonna flip and break it's
gonna fly off because it hasn't set to
that limit so what you're doing is that
you're corrupting that and when you
corrupt it to
such a level aki what's going to happen
is
anywhere it's going to bro intimacy with
your wife you're going to say what the
hell is this you're probably going to be
sick like what i didn't expect this
i'm trying to say it's going to destroy
you that's why they say the eyes doesn't
desire what the the heart doesn't desire
what the eyes don't see
so if we go for example we've never
tasted strawberry we go to a strawberry
farm and we have one strawberry well to
us that's going to be the maybe it's a
little bit sour but we don't know how
like real strawberries
we're going to say well this is the best
fruit we have in our life but now you go
somewhere and you've got 25 different
strawberries oh this is nice oh this is
better wow this is amazing now choice is
a aki comparison is a destroyer of all
pleasure what's happened now you tasted
that now that was better in your head
you remember the last job you had extra
sweet you want that now you've messed up
your dopamine uh you know your dopamine
i'm trying to say you've messed up the
whole structure and what's going to
happen is
you're going to end up destroying the
sisters lives you're going to marry the
sister you
you might find i don't know attractive
or you're looking for a certain body
shape or whatever it may be and you're
gonna after a couple of times intimacy
as a married couple and then you're
gonna think god this is dead now you've
destroyed your life because what you've
done is you have
your fitrah imagine you have glasses
free glasses like this yeah listen these
are not by the way yeah but i'm saying
imagine this is normal vision this is
how it should be you put on something
that distorts everything
do you get it sorry making jokes here
you imagine you're playing these glasses
now you're looking at with this lens
yeah you're going to see everything
different everything is different you
have to see like this but now you've got
this one and you're going to go and
destroy marriages you're going to
destroy sisters yeah i'm trying to say
you have expectations
from a brother's point of view it's like
that with the sisters um sisters don't
know where they're gays when it comes to
other people's lives you know oh his his
husband took him here her hair has his
husband
why are you comparing himself to other
people
why can't you even know nothing but most
of these social influences that you see
with this perfect image of them on
holiday everything looks like it's jenna
but we don't know if that guy's punching
her nose when they go home and she has
to put makeup to fix it
yeah you don't know that and you're
making dua oh allah give me a husband
like that husband like the punches and
knows behind the scenes that you don't
know
i'm trying to say this is our problem
and we had the whole issue of hasanat
and i don't know if you guys remember
yeah yeah i know no
well like that should be that's going to
be a case study in my documentary
towards the end part can you imagine
people making dua allah give me a wife
like this give me your husband can you
imagine if you allah accepted your dua
i don't know
that's why we know that we're not
supposed to even go near zinna not just
not coming in center but don't even go
near zinna
because you might think you might be
like i'm just gonna watch or i'm just
gonna look at this nothing's gonna
happen not it doesn't work like that
yeah that is true
i've got 15 minutes
15.
yeah one five all right all right
what's on your mind
allah man a lot um i was thinking for
people who don't know about what's going
on bro what you got there no it's not
sponsored but um gave it i'm having fun
there we go there we go get that protein
in bro
um
for people who don't know like the
hassanat situation all that um i feel
like that that reference were over their
head so like what happened
what happened like why wouldn't we want
to be you know like those people what
happened with them
well look when i mentioned
the whole hasanah issue
i'm not mentioning it because i feel
like i'm better than them and their
worst
maybe they've repented maybe they're 100
times better than me
my point is not that
my point is the reality that happened
there were a couple who used to do
rookia
and
they seemed like the perfect couple they
used to do stuff together like in the
cup i even promoted them and i don't
regret it to this day because when the
sharia called us to defend them we
defended them when the sharia called us
to
expose the reality we did that
so 100 so we don't have any regrets in
that aspect but they would show a
married you know like you know marriage
you know how married couples are jumping
you know together you know a married
married couple and i thought that's
beautiful because it's not everywhere at
least we have something positive you get
i'm trying to say so you did have your
old people who were hating on them with
petty stuff like oh they're holding
hands and jumping on the bed so what
brother so what
is it haram for a married couple to jump
on the bed so what and these people are
very you know this very oh no everything
is haram so what if they're promoting
marriage avoiding dinner who cares if
they're jumping on the bed are they
naked they're fully covered somewhere oh
okay wow cringe okay let's say most
cringe
no problem
so they were promoting that and i said
look wash them at the end of the day the
promoting got this marriage away from
zina what's better than that
but then behind the scenes
the sister was
dressing up without hijab
clubbing
the brother left islam they all left
islam doing rukiawa left islam
um
charity money all kind of mad stuff that
was going on behind the scenes
so yeah
um
and essentially that's i feel like
to bring the message back home of what
you were saying imagine making dua to be
people like that right because on the
surface you see one thing exactly the
analogy of the lens you see that they
have to be like them and then you find
out that they're not really them so
in all honesty let's just make doth to
be more like uh you know the prophet i
said i'm more like this like though you
know the
predecessors
yeah exactly exactly that's the point
forget other people's lives you don't
know who's going through what broth you
know nothing
you don't nothing about something you
know people making dua you don't know
nothing
you don't know nothing about my life you
don't know if i'm how many jobs you
don't know
what we go through bro you don't know
you don't know don't look at oh he like
you know i don't know bro i don't know
what people think well like that's what
i'm saying don't
just jump to assumptions based on a few
seconds bro how are you
making a dua something so big based on a
five second video of someone's life five
seconds
yeah
let's do this bro we got a few minutes
left
on instagram
was that ten minutes left ten minutes
perfect so on instagram a story that you
know we're filming with you today if
anyone has any questions for a quick q a
so i state
keep your answers as short as possible
but still get the message across can i
ask a question is this live
no no it's not live okay
that's fine i'm
first question
what is and how to give dawah to young
muslim in the west
i think they mean young muslims
i would personally say it's like i try
to i try to look like even dressing up
like this here okay
like i like to look after myself here
okay i have to treat myself i had had a
couple of
jumpers that i had for like a couple of
years so i thought i needed i needed to
upgrade my wardrobe yeah so i went
shopping with
i had one brown t-shirt and deshawn
doesn't like the brown color um so he
keeps complaining so anyways i went i
thought
no i can't tell him why so the thing is
it's i recently got myself
yeah i got myself a couple of jeans one
two three three jeans first time i think
in my life
like i had one jeans i wore it for like
four years
and you know it has a bit of like rip
here like fashion kind of thing yeah but
one day i was putting it on and my toe
got stuck and it ripped it properly yeah
so i like a big like a bulgier so
anyways um i thought i just renew my
wardrobe so um yeah so i went but the
reason i mentioned this because i try to
i do it because i want it for myself i
like to look nice you know all that's
beautiful and he likes beauty so the
thing is also to relate to the
youngsters i'm trying to say the way i
speak sometimes the jokes that i make uh
the way i dress etc i do these things
for a reason i'm trying to say um i'll
be honest well even the glasses like my
old glasses i looked a bit like geeky
like these ones i just thought looks
more fresh i'm trying to say i try to
connect to the youth and relate to them
even via my image even when i'm trying
to stop and talk to them in the street i
talk like sometimes i'm trying to say i
talk like in a certain way to attract
them i think it's a very powerful tool
to use and there's nothing wrong with it
you know
yeah perfectly perfect
right next
what advice would you have about having
self-defense especially in uh situations
like speaker's corner
yeah the thing is like obviously we
stepped up security way before the whole
madness happened you know because with
us
there's we have a lot of issues like
with asphalt we got all kinds of people
on us we've got the takfiris you know
that thing were cafe mustards um i had
one guy who was using my family's
pictures to threaten me and
some stuff like that i made a video
about i tried to meme he didn't come you
know these
these guys are very in the keyboard
warriors yeah
um anyways so the thing is we have that
we have the far right
we have the
these bloody flesh eaters i don't know
these
s pubs i don't know if you guys know
them i don't know if you guys have them
there i would have been lying in a [ __ ]
on the region
yeah then
i don't want to tarnish the the name of
salafis like i i
i i believe i'm from that community you
get it
but they are very extreme group in that
aspect very very harsh one of them comes
to the park i want to mention his name
you know attacking everybody and
everyone's misguided this attitude we
have people like them we have the far
right we have isis supporters uh we have
all everywhere by the muslim internal
conflicts
everywhere you look we got the feminists
we've got the liberalists we've got the
lgbqt
everywhere so physical stuff we've got
like stuff i can't mention but we have
stepped up security in
in the park sounds good got one one
question from a sister another question
from a sister they might be related so
if you want to answer it together so the
first one is
what did you do when you were faced with
so much hate and then the other one was
what's your advice for having no friends
what's your female for what
advice for having no friends like if
someone has no friends
oh no friends
um
when i've got hate
yeah i don't know i don't know if it
sounded like there was a period you guys
said what he did when he was faced with
so much hate
always i've always had hate
i've always had hate
to me
i'm a bit thick skinned
otherwise you can't survive in the
social media scene if you're not fixed
skin
it can mental if it can affect your
mental health
i'm fixing
i don't care what people say about me
people say all kinds of stuff i'm jahil
i can't read the quran ali needs dawah
ali's this ali's that
i don't care brother no problem i
believe you're doing me a favor bob
you're keeping me humble i've got a lot
of people praising me every two seconds
i get stopped you know you're changing
my life etc i'm good but if i didn't
have people like you in my life i don't
know where i would be
so i see as a blessing thank god there's
people like you that says i'm a jahil i
can't do this i can't i'm like no
problem because at the end of the day i
know that don't get to me i know
my concern is myself
my my intentions
that's one thing that i
battle day in day out
my intentions i'm too worried about my
own intentions
to be worried about what people think of
think of me you get it i have an
internal battle within myself and that
i'm at war with so i'm in this i'm at
this big war and there's people throwing
arrows but arrows are nothing i'm i'm
facing a big fire in front of me you
know what i'm trying to say so those
don't mean nothing however sometimes
people that i do know the only thing
that bothers me
is when i know someone so for example i
know rami yeah i've spoken to ramy
before if rami goes and does a video
about me
and says stuff which may not be true i
know rami aghaman said i don't know him
like that but let's suppose rami had my
number i know rami could call me the
fact that he didn't that hurt me because
i wasn't expecting that from you
that's the only kind of things that hurt
me other than that people on social
media you're this i don't care brother i
talk as much it doesn't it doesn't faze
me but people like for example
who talk and i know and i try my best
like to have good relations et cetera
and you turn around and based on
something that you assume
it's not something it's an assumption um
i'm actually going to release a video
because recently i had a bit of a
misunderstanding with abu musab um i
don't know if you guys saw the video
no no no okay they're not from the thing
it's just it's just a
a person that the student of knowledge
misunderstanding i'm actually going to
do a video about 10 misconceptions that
he has of me he did a video like
apologizing you know
he he he he made some comments about me
and
ray a abrupt way which he apologized for
uh but there's a few misconceptions so
misconceptions and fine but because i've
had a bit of interaction with him and
when he did that i didn't expect that
from him like in the context where if
i'm doing something wrong i don't mind
bro correct me if i'm doing haram you
have to correct me but if it's an
assumption that you have of me that you
think i'm committing a haram to come out
in public and stuff like come and talk
to me
if i don't listen
private advice go public on me all day
all day all night i'll be a hypocrite to
tell you not to because i do that i've
done that i've advised people in the
public uh scene how could i not want
that for myself what can they policy is
that
what was the second question
having no friends
having no friends is better than having
friends that call you to the fire
you know and there's you know heading
for the process of selling about
a friend like you know who's a
blacksmith even if you chill next to
them you don't do anything you're going
to be in smoke
you know um and a friend who sells musk
if you chill with him even if he says
nothing to you just right next to him
you're going to leave smelling good
yeah so
if a friend
is bad it's better have nothing i had a
period when i came to islam i had no
friends it's better than having friends
that call me to do haram stuff
i'm better alone i was watching youtube
videos with me that all day
all right one last question because i
tried to skip through all the ones
asking for the for the marriage
documentary but tell them you gotta
watch the whole thing to find out uh
so
advice for revert sisters that are
trying to get married because there's a
stigma okay this is very important i've
discussed this in my marriage
documentary
i'm so sorry i've discussed in my
documentary i've done a whole thing
about it on the app dedicated dedicated
with sister lauren booth she's a reaver
herself yeah
let me tell this very categorically
clear okay sisters who are reversed
listen to me very clearly
you must have a wally a wally is not by
the way not a wally that hey can you be
my wally yeah sure when you get married
community
i don't know what kind of a wally that
is yeah that's i don't know have you
seen that thing called where's wally
finding wooly yeah
yeah maybe that's what that is a wally
is someone that sees you as like their
own sister or daughter or mother and
they are there for you meaning if a
brother comes to get married to you he
is gonna grill well okay why do i wanna
marry you
yeah why why he has to grill her he has
to know that he's gonna face your wally
if he messes up most of the times river
sisters have these wallies that are not
serious can he be the wally the person
that they're getting to know for
marriage is giving them a walley oh
don't worry i'll find you wally oh
masha'allah you give me what is it
subhanallah you find your own wali
someone that's serious someone that
cares about you genuinely cares about
you fears allah he's your body yeah
number one number two this is to avoid
heartache because a lot of brothers
sadly target river sisters um
whatever reason it may be yeah and sadly
this causes some of them to even leave
islam because they're
used and abused yeah okay because they
don't have a wally because brothers know
sisters the other sisters have a world a
lot of headache this sister doesn't have
a wally i'll give her a walley
get married give her a go in a piece
flex with her let me read quran for you
and
no when you're asking for mahada make
sure you ask i don't know what's in
dollars yeah make sure you ask a
substantial i advise sisters to ask
between three to five thousand pounds of
mahara
it's not if a brother really wants to
marry you
three thousand pound is nothing work
five six months you save up
no problem
make sure your mahara is that then you
will know your wall is serious your
mahara is it's not like one little 20
pound ring please no and now the brother
knows okay hold on a second actually i
was here for the wrong reasons now the
ma now the wally looks a bit like a mad
thing yeah he looks a bit like a big hen
and then i've got a mahara free grand uh
i think i'll miss this one then you know
is this brother really after marriage or
is he after something else
all right then that's it
all right
guys if you made it this far comment
down below hashtag bring ali dawa back
for part two
it's a pleasure um what's this called
the best podcast in the dunya the
realest podcast in the dunya the realest
podcast is that's such a sick that's
amazing
yeah that's that's not the name of the
podcast though oh what is it what bro
what do you what do you think the name
is bro take a guess yeah come on come on
the realest podcast in the dunya no no
no that's what we are but that's oh yeah
but what's the name the title
the free muslim musketeers
there we go ah take take away the
musketeers part bro come on
and allowed the marriage documentary to
come out uh when it's perfect perfect
time
for
they're
me
oh my gosh
it was very discreet
they're continued let's continue
yeah no we can't see that there's no
camera what's that
eos
webcam utility yeah
what does that mean is that your sponsor
yo it's a famous couch
i shall look do you come selling it for
1.3 million if anybody wants it oh no
you go for it keep there
yeah do you know how long it took me to
get this guy out of his couch and into
speaker's corner
how long ah
you need tahajud you know they say to
hajj this arrow that doesn't miss a
target
yeah best believe that
yeah this guy he only leaves his house
to go to the front door to put the
rubbish out
do it again with
that do again
do it again
do it again it's like the glasses you're
good am i getting your prescription
i don't know
i don't know i can't see any difference
he put some colorful lights behind me so
i look like yeah yeah yeah
you see the channel only uses these
colorful lights only for his videos so i
have to tell him you know for me you
know love your brother we love yourself
please yeah i want some special effects
in the back i want blue and green lights
yeah yeah that's it is that bad guys all
right um
gorgeous yes wait first off ali are you
ready
yeah i'm ready yeah all right in
charlotte oh it's got the big light now
put it right over is it perfect just
right there
yeah come let's start let's start
uh by the way uh margaret is going to
start in about 12 minutes
if we can
get it out the way in 45 to one hour
that's fine if not we'll have to stop to
pray
all right i thought you were going to
say let's get it done in 11 minutes so
yeah
yeah
yeah i mean we'll play by ear inshallah
yeah no problem all right
we can even do part two no problem any
time but let's pray inshallah inshallah
give give us an estimate of how long it
will take yeah no no about six six
minutes six seven minutes take your time
and take your time make sure this is
sometimes i say have you played uh
maghrib but you might be in a different
country we played also in an hour and a
half
whatever it is make sure you pray
yourself
but it's important bro grammar
especially in arabic is really important
yeah i see the camera turned back on but
what is that a lot with a horror movie
now yeah
guys we're joined for some uh backstage
uh vip access into ali
that's money right there
setting it up they're setting it up so
dark oh my gosh
i think it's funny because like we said
that that's like the famous couch in the
beginning
i mean as rami said welcome back to the
next episode of alidawah after dark
yes now it's about to get
any kids watching this please switch off
i mean bro your camera's just done
it was the lights not the camera
[Music]
all right
cops the cops are here corrupt cops so
my character
is a thing about a video game think
about a movie you think about a book
you have different characters the
character
is uh the expressions the actions the
personality the traits of this
individual
good character would imply obviously
that this person leads
towards good bad would imply that they
lean towards bad but having character in
general uh implies authenticity or at
least i would say good character implies
authenticity
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]